oh this is grown man this is such
a real point
alex jones is more accurate than cnn
so that's good that's good uh
yeah alex jones is more accurate than
cnn yeah
yeah no doubt there's no doubt the alex
jones are gay they're trans actually
he was he was cautious about the frauds
he was what was the deal with the frog
so he thought if you lick the frog
what was the deal there was no licking
that's something
else what he's referring to there is a
toad you can lick that you'll trip you
know yes
that's gonna be our next game yeah so
the thing about the frogs yeah we all
made fun of the genderless frogs that
you there was a study done by yale and
the epa in connecticut of these
waters that had chemicals in them yeah
the frogs were
were being disproportionately turned not
gay but hermaphroditic
so they were developing both sex organs
so alex jones
was actually the most responsible
journalist in america he brought he sort
of brought it back to the more modest
claim of
they're turning the freaking frogs gay
yeah but really he should have said
they're turning the freaking frogs trans
right right but even he knew he could
only touch it so much
um i would say my the reason my answer
is yes is that
first off everything cnn is says is
basically a lie yes
virtually everything they say all the
time is a lie
you can drink to that and i would also
say that jones
and this is really true i've never
watched if you took all the clips i've
ever watched of him
maybe yeah maybe it's five minutes but
i've seen like the screaming stuff
but he sort of has been directionally
right let's say when it comes to is
there a giant sort of globalist
operation that's
sort of taking over the world that we're
now we're seeing through covid and
lockdowns and everything else it's like
that's so he he did he was directly
right about something very big
he did a bit once i thought it was one
of those crazy things he ever said he
said a lot of things are pretty kooky
yeah but he comes and he says
they're they're the globalists the
globalist triacoms are making they're
making human monkey hybrids
so they can do their experiments and
extend their lives and i was just like
okay here we go yeah the human monkey
huh let me just go to santa there come a
human monkey oh my gosh he's right
no they're actually doing that and
admitting that yeah we've got human
monkey hybrids yes
that's like that was a headline like
three weeks ago oh great yeah so
you gotta gotta hand it to it right guy
has gotten a few things right all right
which is more than you can say about cnn
to our impending cancellation
you